une colonne de fumée noire s'élèvent
dans le ciel de severodonezk dans cette
ville stratégique de l'est de l'ukraine
les combats de rue et les bombardements
continuent de faire rage jour après jour
ici plus de 500 personnes sont
actuellement réfugiées dans l' usine
chimique à zot constamment bombardés par
moscou et ses alliés une situation qui
rappelle mario paul et le complexe
métallurgique d'azov talent désormais
sous contrôle russe après des semaines
de résistance et craignait pour
s'emparer des zones du dombass encore
sous contrôle ukrainien le kremlin
pilonnent la région
exemple à dos propre ia ou la ville a
été visé par des frappes aériennes
la nuit dernière j'ai vu une fusée dans
le ciel il ya eu une lueur et puis tout
à coup nous avons entendu un gros boum
j'ai réalisé qu'un missile était tombé
ici aujourd'hui il y en a eu un autre
quelque chose a explosé pas loin et
ensuite il ya eu un gros incendie le
président ukrainien volodimir zelensky a
exhorté ses compatriotes à tenir le coup
dans le donbass jugeant cette bataille
décisive pour l'avenir du pays
nous avons beaucoup de pertes
malheureusement elles sont douloureuses
mais nous devons nous accrocher résister
dans le donbass est crucial
plus l'ennemi subi de pertes - il aura
de force pour continuer l'agression
ailleurs le dombass est la clé pour
décider de qui dominera dans les
semaines à venir
si la russie a proposé l'instauration
d'un couloir humanitaire de quelques
heures pour évacuer les civils de
l'usiné azote lundi les forces du
kremlin ont détruit le dernier pont
reliant la ville à sa voisine licite
chance